the parents of a 15 year old honor
student who was gunned down in a Chicago
Park says justice has finally been
served
a suspected gang member shot and killed
Hadiya Pendleton in 2013 in an apparent
case of mistaken identity yesterday a
jury found the shooter Mikael Ward
guilty of murder the getaway driver
Kenneth Williams was convicted on
Wednesday Dean Reynolds has reaction
from the family of the girl who became a
symbol of Chicago's gun violence idea
Pendleton would have been just so much
collateral damage in Chicago's bloody
gang war except for two things
about a week before her murder she had
performed as a drum majorette at
President Obama's second inaugural
ceremonies congratulations mr. president
and she was shot to death about a mile
from Obama's Chicago residence
unfortunately what happened to ID is not
unique former first lady Michelle Obama
attended ideas funeral ideas family was
just like my family idea Pendleton was
me and I was her but I got to grow up
this week two men were convicted in her
killing in harsh Park on the city's
south side Kenneth Williams drove the
getaway car while Mikhail Ward did the
shooting the incident was apparently a
case of mistaken identity the police
said Williams and Ward thought they were
targeting rival gang members instead
they shot into a crowd of innocence
everybody
Cleopatra Kali is ideas mother because
she did not deserve it April Ward said
her son was framed by the police they
sent there and manipulated
and to say what they wanted to hear the
ward family says they intend to appeal
but idea Pendleton's family said it's
important to get people like Ward and
Williams off the streets and keep them
off justice for CBS this morning Dean
Reynolds Chicago justice for ideas
family events so painful yeah